and leave the water bottle that I'm
gonna kick it off your head wrong okay
okay all right don't move you you can't
move
no no don't move I'm telling you don't
move I'm gonna do I'm gonna do a
practice or no move that's gone boom
tacos
[Music]
I'm a taco hypebeast
I know they're gonna have some good
drops today some people are like is it
early for tacos no it's never too early
I could eat that's that's my life motto
I could eat you just ate I could eat
[Music]
actually have some shows here in town
last night at the Comedy Store and I
told myself that I was my day off
self-care into me self-care you know
what that means
taco lots of them all over town I don't
even stick with one spot like to
diversify like a stock portfolio check
this out it's raining it's hailing I
just saw a rainbow but we'll make
today's special will really make today's
specials that I'm having tacos with
internet legend brie style King calorie
intake ur baby Beluga lookin dude and to
be best friend Andy Milonakis I grew up
watching this mother [ __ ] hilarious
and also I'm gonna meet bill Esparza
taco scholar not even the top of
connoisseur taco say with me we're in a
pursuit of a trailer turn taco truck
there's only one break leg work that's
how you know the taco trucks good only
one of the bright lights work
[Music]
where are we tell us where we are today
well we're in Boyle Heights at one of
the local institutions carnitas Elmo
mall
okay I'm Salamanca Guanajuato and this
is Mexican breakfast here in Boyle
Heights Mexican breakfast what kind of
stuff that guy going on here what cotton
eat that stare specialist are you more
of like a cheerio cornflakes kind of guy
in the morning I think that's what all
the [ __ ] eat really like you know
what I mean like a group maybe Tommy why
can't you eat savory things in the
morning it's just another time and they
don't have to live like that there's no
life to live like there's a better life
so go me for breakfast yeah here in
Boyle Heights we don't even mess with
brunch we just brunch oh I'll get a
mimosa oh I paid $80 shut the [ __ ] up
eat a dollar taco hey they're not a
dollar anymore what's the move here what
do we order we're getting gotta meet
that that's what they're known for it
and we're getting it specifically their
style okay so you're gonna order for us
let's do it okay you ready bro I'm
[ __ ] ready one of us said I snuggle
that gotta meet us mixed us what do you
think makes a taco truck like slap like
like when you pull up to a spot how do
you know it's gonna be good
well I mean I'm looking for certain
things like nicknames right nickname you
see Momo on there that's you know all
those mumbles we show the street name is
yeah yeah I don't know it's like you
know it's more personal
well that's enough to stop if I see that
the other thing is the specialization
you know when I'm going to have gotta
meet us truck or stand they have to be
doing only god Anita's for me
[Music]
yo soy Luis Roberto Costa yaki stuck on
me Padre
Raul Acosta yes toes not--it raka Ron
Schara
yeah even demos kavita's las mejores
carnitas dato Los Angeles Lisa love reto
valkira lo red book these guys they cook
in a castle they cook it slow and its
own fat
it's a confit style and it's a season
Lord it's not just they'll just put lard
in there but they season it with their
secrets you know I don't like to talk
about that because I got a respect the
taquitos one good shot and cottagey does
just means little meats because they
chopped them up
we got a respect to Tokyo we got to eat
let's do it yeah can't wait you do a
little sign of the Cross can't even fold
it is like a like a rack of money Oh
between a good carnita and a bad one I
think the bad ones is all soggy
there's no crisp to it it's all one
texture it's all the drift you know
those are cheater cutting puss you know
cheaters
yeah they boil them you know and then
they put you put fat and water together
and they get all stringy and hard you
want that real cut no fake [ __ ] right
know who got carrot what do you guys say
we hit another spot oh let's go yeah we
got okay second stop the number one
trending taco in Los Angeles man taco de
birria right the area is like the
avocado toast of the Mexican and Latino
community it goes hard it goes hard I
notice the taco truck is really big and
bright it is there's a lot of logos it
doesn't look as mom-and-pop shop like
it's wrapped there is a rack of alleyway
on this one well if the recipe is good
the wrapper don't matter okay hey guys
you know what I like what do you like
tacos dress taco de birria the recipe
areas conventional custom a citrus
cassabi area the race ticket we didn't
have a number before this is this is al
fresco dining on Olympic Boulevard it's
just like inviting us as I eat me fat
boy especially with this the beauty it's
almost like the like the warm broth that
comes with it
are we gonna be able to dip it in there
too oh man yeah guys wait you got the
dip on the side
he's spasming bro you know that's part
of the job you
not at all I'm just say that whoa Kate
like it's like white people I mean we
got one right instagramers you're like
oh my god you got to dip it you have to
dip it in the consomme this taco
knowledge ever got you laid
[Music]
yo me encargo de cocina Liberian salsa
my Khmer tacos de Macedo Moseley's hemos
hecho en dos our visas from Chrissy
Teigen Benny Blanco John Legend Palacios
Lea let loose and Ostra Caminos Will
Venable arias almost he enters
frequently I love the way everybody
dressed differently for this occasion
right green salsa red salsa bowling
shirt
this is the trinakha kiss i vlds and
tijuana style or baja style tacos and
it's beef because again this has been
the last couple years people been going
crazy over these tacos here in LA Roy
it's not like that's the new thing all
the juices are like seeping through and
there's Michel yeah and in Mexico we eat
crunchy tacos tacos Dorados and it's
just Chris on the Kamala and I feel like
you just have to baptize there you know
doc you do oh my god
well hey guys why dip it when you can
pour on oh [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] of our old [ __ ] so
one of the things I've always paid a
close attention to is the vernacular
that they use here at taco trucks so
when I go to order the first thing I
like to say is like a compass okay like
it what's up boss what are some of the
like words or vernacular that people use
to kind of build rapport with the taco
man you know it's like sort of macho
culture and ordering tacos you don't go
like oh what do you guys have you got to
know what they have is they don't that
goes con todo you know con todos
obviously something you gotta go right
that's the oume cos they experience the
taquitos final product right definitely
one of the most amazing tacos I've ever
had this place is [ __ ] insanely good
you mind kicking a little eight bar 16
if you have it goat meat we didn't need
that we ate beef and I'm kind of fat and
I like to rap and I like to wear a
bowling shirt I'm a little bachelor
let me conquer me but I didn't tip it
you can get my digits not like that we
can hang out tacos I told you before I
got hoes do you want one I can lend you
a [ __ ] I don't do all right let's go
[Music]
[Music]
this wired correct me if I'm wrong but
LeBron James co-signed the hell out of
this spot
yeah higher than to feed the
firefighters during the fire yeah that's
correct
how cool is that that's very cool did
you also hear that he would try to
copyright Taco Tuesday and he failed and
he failed what's your thoughts on that
I'm providing that really you don't have
it why not just next just try to take
the name Tuesday oh yeah I'm gonna
copyright Tuesday now get out of here
well to complete our trio of badass
places you know la is about money
supposed to we have lots of people from
Sinaloa
nyaah T and also from Jalisco which is
where my mom for us right and they got
they got good money's gone seven huh you
do yeah my mom's from there well part
the part that makes the good shrimp
tacos here you have ceviches like any
money suppose truck in LA but these guys
specialize in attack bull
we get it you're cool [ __ ] yourself
we got a lot of money suppose trucks and
stands here in LA but these guys are
famous for their tacos that come out on
all right let's do it let's get rich
he's a strong one strong but not as
strong as that uh Bolan way of in a
t-shirt look at some of the government
would what about the ice it's like a
special kind of ice tenemos research on
youngster Honda pasamos is it pregnant
del trabajo de uno ver que que la gente
tiene esta contento comiendo lo que pasa
love the two acids Abajo a miracle
negocio Chris car s algo bonito para una
e please David I'm Jose I promised mr.
Renta's mistress Carlos me gusta la cara
me pan and these are good looking
let's look inside to see show oh yeah
foreplay right there
what do we got here bill we got shrimp
tacos but these are special shrimp tacos
they're deep-fried they're actually
tacos Dorados okay means you put the
filling inside and you deep-fry the
whole thing and and they put this like
fermented like sauce on top and avocado
and it's not spicy just has a great
balance flavor
okay let's try it I want to try it oh
it's kind of like a shrimp fritter it's
like a bunch of mixed up cut up shreds a
good work mix with the batter we're
always gonna get mad why you're not
supposed to talk about the inside oh
really
well why not I mean if you buy it you
can just see for yourself
Terrell you better get over yourself
buddy
I've had thoughtful Dorado I never had
him in shrimp but I'm telling you the
sauce with the guac slices on top
slaps man earlier we were talking about
how you know you look for the nicknames
right you like Momo but the other thing
is is like big Mexico versus little
Mexico when I found these guys right on
the side of their truck it said send one
little slaw goes not only is it is it a
region but it's a micro region you know
a sub region and to me that's it okay
you got to stop here and when people
represent their hometown you know call
out their hometown you know it's gonna
be serious please well I had a good time
here man
can you take us out with another one
beatbox or no beatbox you do a cappella
the Sun I want to do a cappella I don't
like your beats so like my beats pretty
good oh well you roll your eyes no I
mean yeah let's hear acapella okay
acapella shrimp shrimp I walk with a
limp I'm not a [ __ ] I'm a taco pimp I'm
eating [ __ ] that's crispy I'm like Bill
Bixby that's a name that I know in my
head but I don't know who he is really
I'm so silly
hanging out with hey soos not Jesus I
mean in tacos and Reese's Pieces
that's a weird combo what did I say
before I got hoes is this mine it's not
chose that's a shitty cliche joke he's
not gonna like it but I'm really excited
oh my god I'm gonna break this [ __ ] and
put it in my fat mouth then I'm going in
the south and find some fried chicken
I'm finger Lake down mmm my knees close
Holly's goes baby
I told my daughter when air she breathes
her boyfriend move his first test is
gonna be sharpen a knife though if he
doesn't pass he's out the door
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter tacos tacos
bro hey Suz Trejo is in the building
tacos con todo a new show on first we
feast Tuesdays at 11 a.m. this is the
initiation a last dab taco oh yeah hey
Suz Trejo
welcome to the family man thanks man
this is gonna hurt tomorrow